a Saudi journalist and former
intelligence operative turns dissident
goes missing at the Saudi embassy in
Turkey with reports that a Saudi death
squad chopped him up while still alive
and for some reason I have been assured
by the mainstream media this is all
Donald Trump's fault we will analyze the
devil in the details how this is being
totally misreported and what the US
response should be then the me2 movement
boomerang swings back and clobbers
democrats on the head alexandria Ocasio
cortez like totally you know reveals why
Millennials don't understand anything
Kleenex says women are just as
disgusting as men and Thomas Jefferson
gets accused of a sex scandal on this
day in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
so much to get to today this story about
the Saudi journalist intelligence
operative former Politico Islamist
whatever the the story about him being
disappeared and probably killed at the
Saudi embassy in Turkey is one of the
great examples of fake news in the
mainstream media and how it's used by
politicians we'll get to all of that in
a second first let's make a little bit
of money honey because you know the
future is so bright right now the
economy is going so everything is so
good the future is so bright you got to
buy shades and that's why you need
blinds calm window treatments is one of
those solace terms for something
necessary but absolutely boring your
blinds and you don't think about them
until you move or until they break or
they fold out whatever when they're
right everything in your home looks
better when they're wrong everything in
your home looks cheap don't cheap out
taking the time to pick out blinds and
buy blinds it sounds expensive it sounds
far too adult you know it's I don't
that's not something I want to do but
blinds.com makes it really easy if
you're not sure what you want or even
where to start
blinds calm we'll give you a free online
design consultation this is really
important I have no I would live in a
heap of trash and like foam if I have if
I were living alone don't be like that
just have them design it for you it's
much easier send them pictures of your
house they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
and furniture in specific rooms best
part is if you accidentally mismeasure
it or pick the wrong color if you screw
up blinds comm will remake the blinds
for free for a limited time don't say I
never did nothing for you get up to 20%
off of everything at blinds.com
when you use the promo code Michael mi
CH AE L that is blinds.com promo code
Michael mi CH AE L for 20% off
everything faux wood blinds cellular
shades roller shades and more
what is it blinds.com promo code michael
mi CH AE l rules and restrictions apply
because they apply to everything in this
life ok let's get to this saudi
journalist you know dissident type guy
jamal khashoggi what do we know he is a
Saudi guy he worked for The Washington
Post he lived in the United States
briefly but he had worked previously
with the Saudi royal family
and he walks into the Saudi embassy in
Turkey he doesn't walk out we also know
that I think 15 members of the Saudi
government arrived in Turkey that day
they left pretty quickly and there are
claims that he was killed in the Saudi
embassy and chopped up wealth still
alive doesn't sound great the way this
is being spun by the mainstream media
first of all is that this is somehow
Trump's fault the Trump needs to like do
something about this Trump needs to get
rid of our agreements with Turkey with
regard to selling weapons 100 billion
dollar arms deals whatever as Saudi
Arabia rather so this is how it's being
spun he and the guy Jamal khashoggi he's
being spun as a left-wing progressive
liberal pro-democracy you know reformer
guy against the Saudi royal family which
is not willing to reform and is
oppressive the real truth is far more
complicated than that the first question
that you have to ask yourself when you
hear about this story is why am I
supposed to care why am I supposed to
care that the Saudi government took out
this guy that took out this former he
formerly worked with them I guess
Jamal cushaw he was aligned with other
with another faction of the Saudi royal
family than the one that is currently in
power under Mohammed bin Salman so you
know a guy whose political fortunes have
changed has been killed by the Saudi
government why am I supposed to care
about that I don't mean to sound callous
or cold-hearted or anything like that
but we know that the Saudi royal family
commits heinous acts all the time and
has for decades and decades we know that
it's one of the most repressive regimes
on earth why am i am I supposed to care
about this one they do it all of the
time my question for those who would
call us callous for asking that question
is why don't you care about the the
beheadings that are happening all the
time the clamping down on political
dissidents why don't you care about that
why is it this one in particular I'm not
I don't really understand what new
information is being conveyed by this
killing of a dissident guy is there
anything new if we had our arms deal
with Saudi Arabia - we
ago why would we change it now it's not
like the government has changed its
stripes if anything the government is
getting a little less repressive there
they're liberalizing certain laws
they're letting women drive for the
first time in a very long time they're
opening up certain movie theaters
they're you know little little freedoms
are being opened up even economic
freedoms they're now starting to do a
little bit of business with Israel and
that is the biggest issue that's
actually where this gets down to and it
shows that Jamal khashoggi being put up
by the left-wing is this messianic
figure you know this this progressive
secular Westerner is was far from that
so what does this actually prove to me
it proves to me that if you pal around
with jihadists and things aren't going
to turn out very well that's that's the
only conclusion I can draw from this
because we know that Jamal cushaw he
piled around with his lamas
for decades and by the way now the left
now that we're pointing this out that
this guy Pal de round with Islamists
with radicals even with Osama bin Laden
now that people are pointing this out
the left is saying this is a smear
campaign by right-wingers trying to
defend president Trump's relationship
with the Saudis
president Trump didn't develop the u.s.
relationship with the Saudi royal family
we've had it for a very long time but to
call us smear merchants it's it's not
the right wing which is coming up with
these connections between khashoggi and
terrorists in Hamas terrorists in
al-qaeda terrorists like Osama bin Laden
this has been known for decades and
actually it's left-wing papers to
Haaretz and Israel is reporting on all
of this so I don't really buy any of
that what do we know we know that Jamal
cushaw he was in Islamist he's he was a
lifelong member of the Muslim
Brotherhood he favored radical aspects
of the Muslim Brotherhood we know that
he was a regime insider as well so not
it's not just as simple as a journalist
it's a guy who worked with the Saudi
royal family for a long time and we know
that he was working on their behalf in
the 1980s when he was paddling around
with Osama bin Laden by all reports when
he was hanging out with Osama bin Laden
he was trying to end the feud between
the Saudi royal family and Osama bin
Laden but he was hanging out with him
for a long time there was a photo that
was uncovered I believe by Haaretz
which shows Jamal khashoggi holding an
RPG rocket-propelled grenade with
terrorists in Afghanistan in the 1980s
we know that Jamal cushaw he defended
supporters of suicide bombings that he
vigorously defended Hamas the brutal
terrorist group in the Middle East we
know that that according to Al Arabiya
he tried to get Osama bin Laden to be a
little less violent but when Osama bin
Laden died
Jamal cushaw he apparently cried and
talked about how he wept when Osama bin
Laden died now he after September 11th
he he turned away from Osama bin Laden
he said that's no good ok fine but he he
wept when bin Laden died
so again Turkey says that it has the
audio recording of Jamal khashoggi being
killed by the Saudis maybe it does maybe
a dozen I have very little reason to
believe Turkey but in this case I have
very little reason to disbelieve Turkey
because the Saudis commit heinous crimes
all the time there are now also reports
that Saudi Arabia is looking for a
replacement for the Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman he's that he's the
new guy in town he's been hailed in the
West as a reformer he actually has
instituted certain reforms and pretty
major reforms in so much as doing a
little bit of business with Israel you
know obviously the kind of
headline-grabbing ones letting women
drive but he does seem to have an eye
toward the future it would be a very
very bad idea for Saudi Arabia to
replace this guy right now I really
think it's a bad idea the arguments
against the crown prince of Saudi Arabia
or that he's not in favor of democracy
in the kingdom great why on earth would
we be in favor of democracy in Saudi
Arabia how has have our experiments and
democracy panned out in other repressive
Islamist countries not very well why why
are we supposed to conclude now that a
democratic Saudi Arabia would be any
more peaceful for the kingdom for the
region and for the United States than a
democratic Saudi Arabia I don't really
buy that and you know some of the
so-called pro-democracy agitators in
Saudi Arabia have pretty radical
Islamist ties even more radical than the
Saudi royal family
okay what else the other thing is being
dinged for is that he's developed a
pretty good relationship with Donald
Trump again this is nothing new the
Saudi royal family has had a
relationship with the US for a long time
but because everyone hates Trump on the
Left they're trying to ding him for that
as well
I highly recommend you read a piece
today co-written by Michael Duran
Michael Duran is an excellent foreign
policy analyst it's in the New York Post
it I think presents a fair take on who
cushaw he is who Mohammed bin Salman is
and what the relationship is between
those families you know to call him a
dissident journalists who fled to
America that that presents one picture
it's not like he fled to America 10 or
15 or 20 years ago it's not like he fled
to America after he was paddling around
with bin Laden and he suddenly had an
awakening he fled to America after the
political tides turned in Saudi Arabia
and there's a new crown prince in town
okay
here are some other things by the way
that Jamal khashoggi
wrote about that paint a different
picture he said quote Saudi Arabia now
believes its interests lie in facing
Islamists who were supposed to be its
historical allies I often hear Saudi
Arabian intellectuals on television
attacking political Islam and my answer
to them is that Saudi Arabia is the
mother and father of political Islam so
you've got this guy Kush oggi who was
killed extolling the virtues of Islamism
of political Islam the vicious ideology
that we've been fighting now explicitly
for 15 years and yet the left in America
is expecting us to rend our garments and
gnash our teeth because a defender of
political Islam has been killed by his
government I'm not saying that I'm happy
about the killing I'm not saying I am
devastated about the killing I'm saying
when you pal around with jihadists and
radical Islamists bad things are going
to happen to you he goes on he
criticizes the the leftist project of
opposing political Islam and he says
that Saudi Arabia has lost its moral
compass it lost its moral compass not
because it's a embraced political Islam
be cooked but because it opposes
political
oh um this is not something that's being
presented in the mainstream media we
also know that
khashoggi supports air Juwan in Turkey
strong Pro Islamist leader of Turkey and
he was hoping for an alliance between
the sods and Turkey I don't see how this
benefits the United States I don't see
how it's in the interest of the United
States Oh
part of the reason why Khashoggi is
getting this red carpet treatment and
this killing is being presented is
totally unprecedented horrifying
shocking as if we didn't know that this
was this sort of thing was going on for
decades
part of the reason is that when he got
to the United States he allied with
certain former Obama administration
officials he allied with the political
left in the United States from his post
at the Washington Post which he's had
for a little while
and so part of that was hiding his I
think true political beliefs and his
demonstrable political activity for
decades all of all of which I don't want
this to be misconstrued I don't want it
to seem as though I'm defending the
Saudi royal family at killing some
dissident I don't share a religion with
the Saudi royal family I don't share a
views of government with the Saudi royal
family I don't share views of political
philosophy with the Saudi royal family I
don't care I you know I have no
intention of ever going to Saudi Arabia
what I'm saying is this is nothing new
and the people who are opposing the
Saudi regime can be pretty awful people
too they may actually even be worse you
know one of the arguments for defending
the Saudi royal family for maintaining
an alliance with the Saudi royal family
is that the devil we know is better than
the devil we don't throughout our
encounters in the Middle East this is
very often proven to be the case just
take the case of Mubarak in Egypt do we
really believe that Egypt is better off
now that the United States relationship
is better off now after we hoisted our
longtime ally Hosny Mubarak years ago do
we really believe it's how is that
better off how are we better off if
pro-democracy forces enter some of these
oppressive countries and then through
democracy through voting Institute even
more oppressive even more tyrannical
even more anti Western regimes how is
that in our interest how is that in
anybody's interest if one of cushaw he's
chief criticisms of the Saudi royal
family is that they're too pro-israel
and they're not supporting Hamas enough
or something like that why on earth
should we be defending that why should
we be horrified why should we be
clutching our pearls I don't get it at
all
I think the reason it's getting so much
play is because there's a midterm
election coming up they got nothing the
Democrats have nothing to attack trump
for so they're just grasping at straws
they're trying to grasp anything at all
that they can use to cuddle him with but
people need to take a real view you know
we talked yesterday about how when
people get angry they go mad and when
they go mad they get stupid they start
behaving in really stupid political ways
this is a good example of that
you know we people don't know anything
myself included
people do not know anything relatively
about the political machinations of
Saudi Arabia Turkey and Iran people
don't know the players involved they
don't know how deep this runs and
everybody wants to pretend that they're
an expert on this issue and Saudis bad
and Mohammed bin Salman bad and Jamal
khashoggi good the reality is so much
more complex and when we when we just
buy a shallow narrative of this we can
get ourselves into a lot of trouble both
as a matter of foreign policy and for
domestic politics don't buy into it is
it is it bad when a government kills its
people without due process yes
governments do it all the time it's
happened for decades certainly it's
happened in Saudi Arabia there is no new
information here now how can we react to
this the killing was extrajudicial what
can we do we can hopefully leverage this
killing to get some concessions out of
Saudi Arabia you know there is the
famous Saudi Arabian textbook
controversy which is emblematic of the
education of young Saudis into
anti-western anti America and anti
Israeli obviously ideologies perhaps we
can leverage this situation to gain some
concessions from them to turn the stance
of the regime a little less
Western turn it a little bit more in the
direction that we want it to go in the
interest of the United States I'm all
for that
I'm all for leveraging this I have no
sentimentality no saccharine love of the
Saudi royal family but let's be clear
I'd the people who are opposing the
Saudi royal family are pretty awful
themselves and it's in many ways they
oppose our interests in a far greater
way and fortunately we have the Saudis
there to oppose the influence of Iran in
the Middle East just keep all of those
things in mind and most importantly is
your what are we now 18 days out or
something from the from the midterm
elections don't don't let the Democrats
take this bizarre random incident that
happened in Turkey and try to use it for
political leverage coming 18 days out it
is it's a cynical political ploy by the
left and it could have consequences both
politically and for for our foreign
policy don't buy it
you know the people I think who are
screaming about the Saudi royal family
that most I don't know that they've ever
even googled the guy who was killed I
don't know that you've got to view these
things pretty clearly but we don't have
a lot of clear thinking anymore we'll
get to that in a second with them with
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes I do want to
turn back to the midterms because this
me too thing has totally boomerangs back
and clobber Democrats you know this is
another example of why you shouldn't let
your passions run away with you in
politics you should get all of the
information first because this made to
thing is clobbering them there is now an
ad out supporting the GOP congressmen
French he'll now he racial says he
wasn't behind this ad he's condemned the
ad he says it's outrageous but the whole
premise of this me to movement and
specifically the Kavanagh part of it is
that all women must be believed
regardless of any evidence they have all
women all claims of sexual misconduct
should be believed all men accused of
sexual misconduct should be presumed
guilty until proven innocent and this
has huge effects on and huge relation to
American history specifically American
racial history don't forget the book To
Kill a Mockingbird is about a false rape
allegation of a
white woman against a black guy and she
made it up and it was a hoax and it was
had serious racial consequences so
there's this great ad out now supporting
GOP congressmen French he'll just take a
listen think about what's happening in
Washington our congressman French Hill
and the Republicans know that it's
dangerous to change the presumption of
innocence to a presumption of guilt
especially for black men if the
Democrats can do that to a white Justice
of the Supreme Court with no evidence no
corroboration and all of her witnesses
including her best friend say it didn't
happen what will happen to our husbands
our fathers or our sons when a white
girl lies on them girl white Democrats
will be lynching black folk again
turnout always told my son don't be
messing around with that if you get
caught she will cry rape I'm voting to
keep congressman French here and the
Republicans because we have to protect
our men and boys we can't afford to let
white Democrats take us back to bed old
days of race verdicts life sentences and
lynches when a white girl screams rape
paid for by black Americans for the
president's agenda not authorized by any
candidate or candidates committee that
is too real that it I think that has
been disqualified from the public
airwaves for being too real
they say I'm sorry you're not allowed to
have political ads that are that real
you're not allowed political ads that go
back one to really the heart of this
matter but also that refer to Democrats
long history of racial violence and
demagoguery so a really good ad
obviously the it is outrageous of the
congressman has had to distance himself
from it but it makes a great point you
know this this regime this political
movement of me too is lawless it's anti
law and it's lawless it says that any
allegation you can destroy a man's
career with just a few words no
corroboration no evidence in the case of
Christine Ford not only did she have no
evidence she kept changing her story and
all the people she names there including
her lifelong female friend said it
didn't happen they never met the people
there it just didn't
happen and yet how many people in
America still believe Christine Ford's
story or one of Christine Ford stories I
don't know she kept changing them how
many believed that Brett Kavanaugh is
not only a groper or was a groper when
he was 16 but was an attempted rapist
and even almost a murderer because the
story you know kept changing how many
people believe that it's very a really
long-lasting effect and you see it all
around and there is a racial component
to it don't just believe the ad for a
French he'll go back to to kill a
mockingbird go back to 19th and early
20th century American history this is
not this is not a joke
and because all nature is but art
unknown to thee because everything every
time the Democrats try to make a point
reality swings back and punches them in
the face this has actually happened you
know the lynching of Emmett Till came
about because Emmett Till allegedly
fourteen-year-old black boy allegedly
hit on a white woman and a lynch mob
came and killed him for it for that
allegation and now you've got the left
denying that this would ever happen not
it was not a chance it would never
happened in Brooklyn in New York a
nine-year-old black boy was accused by a
white woman of grabbing her derriere in
a in a supermarket the woman's clearly
unhinged she ended up calling the police
and saying he assaulted me he grabbed me
he grabbed my derriere and a
nine-year-old boy and then they looked
at security camera footage never
happened they can they can prove that it
didn't happen she's a nut and she called
the cops on the kid it's not like she
just said oh you don't do that or say
said to his mother don't do that she
called the police on him and then it
turns out it was fake it didn't happen
it was a hoax so one I just want to
point out for the believe all women
thing there are hoaxes
Jackie Coakley Tawana Brawley countless
sexual assault hoaxes in recent years
the reason that you can't believe all
women just because they're women is that
it is unfair to actual victims of sexual
assault it actually doesn't take sexual
assault seriously when you believe crazy
people
and we should take sexual assault
seriously because it is a heinous crime
so I love this kid he the woman the
crazy woman who accused him of this his
name Teresa Klein the nine-year-old kid
is Jeremiah Harvey and you know she's
trying to ruin his life at this Brooklyn
deli the ABC News interviewed the the
nine-year-old kid and said do you
believe this woman I love his answer I
don't forgive this woman at all I think
she was crazy I think she had something
going on with her I think she had a
special ill well and she needs help and
she really needs help for you you tell
him tell him Jeremiah now you know I
think he should forgive in time but this
is a perfectly appropriate answer in the
moment yeah she has a special kind of
ill she's crazy she needs help she needs
to get help
play it again tell him again Jeremiah
because all the Democrats need to hear
this you're talking to all of them I
don't forgive this woman at all I think
she was crazy I think she had something
going on with her I think she had a
special ill well and she needs help
and she really needs help for life she
doesn't need help and thank goodness
that there was security camera footage
because look it's funny the kid is
stating this perfectly he's really
spelling out what the left needs to hear
but thank goodness there was security
camera footage because if not who knows
what would have happened at the very
least his mother would have yelled at
him and spanked him and sent him to
timeout I don't know he would have
gotten in trouble for this and this it
is a particular incident that also
represents a lot of other incidents you
got kids getting expelled from college
because of uncorroborated unverified
allegations not taken to the police not
taken to the justice system but tallied
up by kangaroo courts of professors who
have no business investigating and
prosecuting serious crimes you've got
Supreme Court justices having their
characters assassinated because of
unverified claims it goes all the way up
it's you know this nine-year-old kid in
a Brooklyn deli is a great
example and symbol of of the dangers of
what could happen if we take away due
process and we take away the presumption
of innocence and me too is striking back
it is striking back against Democrats
specifically Democrats on the Judiciary
Committee this is just too delicious let
me take a little sip of my tumbler first
before I get to this wonderful story mmm
mm-hmm
just as good as I remembered them
senator sherrod Brown Democrat from Ohio
running against Jim Renacci Jim Renacci
and his campaign is now coming out with
an allegation that sherrod Brown member
of the Senate Judiciary Committee
sexually harassed and assaulted a woman
in the 80s I love this I love that it's
30 years later I love that it allegedly
happened in the 1980s I love that it's a
political opponent bringing it against a
Democrat and I love that it's a Democrat
on the Judiciary Committee very rarely
do we see perfect examples of karma very
rarely do these things hit exactly the
way that they came out and that's that's
what's happening here so according to
the Renacci campaign quote this
encounter oh this is actually according
to the accuser purported victim she said
this account happened after sherrod
Browns divorce she described quote an
unexpected uninvited unwanted in sudden
advance roughly pushing her up against a
wall it did not stop after she expressed
dismay and very firmly pulled away
explaining that was not her style nor
why she was there although she was able
to defuse the situation she got out it
did shake her up and she told friends
about it as soon as she got home this
allegation is about a thousand times
more credible than anything christine
ford has said regarding Brett Kavanaugh
and that and this doesn't sound that
credible either I'll be perfectly frank
this accusation against sherrod Brown
unless they can bring some more evidence
isn't terribly credible it is a thousand
ten thousand times more credible than
anything christine ford said
it's almost a one-to-one it happened in
the 1980s okay
except that sherrod Brown in this case
was an adult who had been divorced in
the case of Christine Ford's accusation
Cavanaugh was 17 years old then sherrod
Brown according to this accusation
pushed her up against a wall Pinder used
his body
it was unwanted and it was rough that
was the same allegation against teenage
Brett Kavanaugh except in this case
sherrod Brown was apparently stone-cold
sober and in the case of the Ford
allegation Cavanaugh was drunk maybe if
he was even in the room then she
expressed dismay Ford expressed dismay
both of them expressed dismay and in
both cases they didn't stop and and then
in both cases the women just got out of
it they were able to get out of there
fortunately and but it still shook them
up the difference here is that the woman
accusing Democrat sherrod Brown of this
kind of conduct apparently told her
friends immediately after it happened
and the and the friends are
corroborating it in the case of
Christine Ford she didn't tell anybody
for 30 30 years over 30 years and then
her story changed a million times and
then the friends that she said could
corroborate it didn't corroborate it and
actually refuted it this is so much Oh
also both of them wanted to remain
anonymous
the woman accusing sherrod Brown is
anonymous the woman Christine Ford
wanted to remain anonymous until the
Democrats leaked the story and what is
sherrod Brown how has he responded to
this this dirty rotten hypocrite he said
this is character assassination you're
damn right it's character assassination
absolutely and I hope you enjoy every
second of that character assassination I
mention this during the Ford thing I
said if we actually want to stop this
sort of baseless smearing these things
that discourage good people from going
into politics that make a mockery of our
system of justice that make a mockery of
the presumption of innocence Democrats
have to feel it too and one of the
perfect Democrats to feel it is feeling
it now
sherrod Brown Democrat enjoy your
character assassination enjoy this
perfect one to one can't wait to see our
Democrats respond you probably haven't
heard about this story because nobody is
covering it surprise surprise well maybe
it'll be covered in Ohio before the
midterm elections I also have to thank
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
as always occasional cortex as Steve
Hayward says because she has perfectly
exemplified why Millennials don't
understand anything at all she was doing
an interview with Jimmy Kimmel here is
just a quick clip of of the poetic
diction of Alexandria Ocasio Cortes beat
ten-time incumbent a guy who just
assumed that he was gonna win and you
came out of nowhere you were working as
a bartender and decided that it would be
a good idea to run for office it's
really one of the most remarkable
stories I've ever heard you stop and
think about this from time to time ago
yeah believe this is happening yeah a
year ago wait in the party yeah yeah
they do and it's yeah yeah their own
hometown yeah absolutely and you know I
don't know I don't know if it's because
we're from the Bronx it's like exotic to
us yeah no my husband is a huge fan of
yours
motion-activated chachki behind me
that's like singing jingle bells
actually yeah like like yeah yeah like
the thing you know like about that clip
like is it shows like how clear speech
is reflective of clear thinking like you
know and that's why you know like it's
so totally hard you know you know do you
know do you know yeah yeah man I know
this is how Millennials talk we all do
it even I do it sometimes I'll
occasionally slip in a like or a yeah or
a you know sometimes I'll do it for
comic effect sometimes I'll do it just
in my speech and this is a very bad
thing people should refrain from doing
this - right well is to think clearly to
speak well is to think clearly when you
don't speak well when you don't write
well you're not thinking clearly very
often it's reflective of how you're
thinking you must avoid all of these
likes and um and yes the other thing
that's reflective of is the relativist
presumptions and premises and culture
that Millennials are in you know man
like yeah millennia
no longer say I think they say what do
they say they say I feel like they don't
say I think they don't say I believe
they say I feel like well I just feel
like blah blah blah you know I feel like
blah blah blah they won't say that was a
delicious dinner they'll say that dinner
was like really good you know it was
like really good it wasn't really good
I'm saying it was like really good the
reason that people do this
subconsciously unconsciously or
consciously is because they want to
distance themselves from making a claim
because there's no such thing as the
truth to these people there is only your
truth and my truth and like who am i man
to say what like the truth is you know
so it's always like it's always a simile
it's always similar to this thing but
not quite that thing I'm I'm never
making a claim
I'm always explaining my feelings about
the claim I feel like it's a really bad
way of thinking and the way that you
speak is gonna dictate how you think
because the words are the stuff of our
consciousness the words or the medium of
how we think so if you use to base
language if you use a vague language if
you use Squishy language you're gonna
think in a vague debased and squishy way
do not be like occasional cortex be like
like you know like man a serious thinker
and use precise language and use hard
language and use blunt language do it as
best you can the culture is stacked
against you and trying to get you not to
do that try to do that on your own now
I've got so much more advice and so many
more pearls of wisdom and these things
and a lot more to cover on this day in
history on how Kleenex is finally
capitulating to feminists and admitting
that feminists or disgusting is any man
and this caravan at the border all of
that will just happen at daily wire.com
if you're on facebook and youtube go
over come on man go over there like come
on you know yeah it'll be really fun
yeah you'll get me you'll get the end
replayed and sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag you had to ask questions in
the conversation none of that matters
you'll also get to see us at Politico
and you'll get to Stream our appearance
of politican over the weekend but you'll
get this and this these leftist tears
they're like oh they're like
oh yeah oh yeah they are like so so good
and they're really important this is the
sherrod Brown vintage this is the
Democrat Senate Judiciary me - boomerang
vintage and it's it's a young vintage
it's only going to mature it's only
gonna get better go to daily wire.com
we'll be right back
there's a French expression processions
do salem em shows the more things change
the more things stay the same in the
American idiom obviously they some
things get worse the language gets worse
of Cassio gets worse the me to movement
descends into these awful things but so
many things stay the same I just came
across this clip from 1991
it's an appearance of Robin Williams the
late great Robin Williams on the Johnny
Carson show and he's describing the
confirmation hearings of Justice
Clarence Thomas one of the great
justices on the court a brilliant guy
here is how Robin Williams describes him
I've been watching the Supreme Court
hearings it's a little amazing mr.
Thomas your opinion of Roe versus Wade
I'd prefer to float okay come on he was
a good boy
they can't get real answers out of him I
mean how do they get people that people
have no legal opinions no written
opinions they basically four short weeks
ago
I was driving truck now I'm sitting on
the highest court in the land thanks to
George Bush home study course you too
could be a Supreme Court justice you get
it he was an idiot what an idiot he
doesn't Clarence Thomas he doesn't even
have any opinions he does any emini ways
a judge is a judge and he has a lot of
written opinions and he ran a lot of
important offices but any went to Yale
Law School by the way a top law school
in the country but he is like an idiot
you know he's like you know like like
he's an idiot and this was the attack
they always do this and when Clarence
Thomas wasn't an idiot he was a sexual
assault he was a he was a black man in a
high-tech lynching being accused without
any evidence of sexual assault an
oversexed black man was the image that
was being painted by the left and they
would go back and forth on this you
heard what even Robin Williams alludes
to it there oh he was a good boy oh he
was a good boy making fun of the
character witnesses that came up for
Clarence Thomas the same exact thing
making the same jokes 27 years ago for
the same reason and Robin Williams even
admits the same reason Roe vs. Wade why
did he bring up Roe vs. Wade was it to
make a fairly lame joke get it Roe
versus Wade I prefer to float and they
weren't all winners you know sometimes
Robin Williams is very funny sometimes
he had some clunkers that was one of
them but it's Roe vs. Wade that's what
it was all about it's what it's gonna be
about we like to flatter ourselves
especially on the left they like to
flatter themselves and say this is the
moment this is the crisis it's always a
crisis the Saudi Arabia thing it's
always a crisis the new crisis that's
the view of politics on the left that's
the view of politics from rationalists
there's always a new crisis that we have
to fix that's not the view of politics
from conservatives and it shouldn't be
it's not a crisis Saudi Arabian
government behaving like the Saudi
Arabian government is not a crisis if
that's a crisis you need to do a little
more homework you got you got to calm
down
a Justice who interprets the
Constitution as it was to be interpreted
at the time of
that's not a crisis that's the opposite
of a crisis but they'll always try to
make it up that way they're gonna do it
for the next judge that we put up to the
Supreme Court they're gonna do it for
the federal judges as well it's not a
crisis calm down don't be fooled by that
kind of language Oh Clarence Thomas he's
an idiot because Robin Williams said to
some comedian on late-night said so
Oh Cavanaugh he's impassioned he's this
he's a bet no he's a frat boy he doesn't
know anything now don't buy it it's this
it's so tired it's they do it all the
time and they whip people up into a
frenzy
there's no frenzy to be had there to
consider the new crisis that they've
made the feminists have made out of
Kleenex if you've heard this story
Kleenex has had at various sizes of
tissues and for the last 62 years
they've had a man-sized tissue
I say man-sized tissue what does that
bring to mind bigger stronger capable of
dealing with grosser things more
disgusting things yes that's what the
man-sized tissue was because men are
bigger and they're stronger and they're
more disgusting that's a biological fact
feminists have taken issue with this it
was one of the most popular products at
Kleenex 3.4 million customers per year
according to Kleenex but it's very bad
it's very bad you know because it's
gendered or we who are you to say that
men are bigger than women they are
obviously but who are you to say it who
are you to say that men are stronger
than women
they are obviously but who are you to
say it's a denial of reality and Kleenex
has capitulated to it and it's ironic
because what feminists want that the
implicit claim of feminists who take
issue with man-sized tissues is that
women are just as big and gross and
disgusting as men and when when it comes
to feminists I can't disagree on the
whole on average I can't disagree so
congratulations feminists you've you've
gotten rid of the man-sized tissues
you've proven that some women are just
as disgusting as men and you've you've
thought reality on the latest
Battlefront congratulations
there is a caravan coming up to the
border there are 4,000 illegal aliens
who promised to cross over it this is
sponsored in large part by Pueblo sin
Fronteras
people without borders and left-wing
group that gets funding from George
Soros plus on Jerusalem MSHA's of course
these things are constantly happening
this is a bigger one though this has
happened before
there are 4,000 people now on average
the United States border patrol arrests
thousand people a day can be as high as
2,000 people can be a little shorter
there were actually sixteen thousand six
hundred and fifty eight family members
people are coming here in families who
were arrested in September by Border
Patrol those are just the ones that they
caught a lot of people pouring over this
border President Trump responded he said
we're gonna cut off aid to El Salvador
we're gonna cut off aid to Honduras
we're gonna work in a ding Mexico this
was a perfect response and I've talked
to friends who were real Trump critics
real never Trump errs whatever and they
agreed this is the perfect response he
actually could go a little farther with
this because these these guys should
never make it to the US border they
should be stopped at the Mexico southern
border and absolutely we should threaten
to cut off aid with all these guys we
should also threaten to tax or cut off
remittances from the United States from
Mexican nationals who make it into the
United States and send money back into
Mexico through Western Union through
telegram services through money order
services we should threaten to cut that
off we tax it heavily if President Trump
threatened to 50% tax on those
remittances you would see Mexico do
something about this and he should do it
he should be pitiless about it it is
such an affront to our sovereignty to
our Democratic Republic to the ability
of Americans to govern themselves when
you have people pouring over the border
invading the country and you can't do
anything about it
you we the people who govern ourselves
who were supposed to govern ourselves
can't do anything about it it's an
affront and it's a huge winner for
Republicans yeah I think something like
the majority of Democrats depending on
which poll you look at the majority of
Democrats oppose this and are horrified
by so many aspects of illegal
immigration even down to the so-called
dreamers you know these these kids who
didn't choose to be here even down to
that level
the majority of Democrats oppose making
amnesty for them a top priority this is
a slam dunk for Republicans they should
turn it up to 11 especially as the
midterms of
Roach Trump should send the National
Guard down there he should cut off
- he should tax remittances he should
threaten to cut off aid do it or all it
could do is help Republicans and it's
the right thing to do and it would be
good for the country on this day in
history in 1796 just to remind you that
Pusa challenged bruce'll mm shows the
more things change the more things stay
the same our third president Thomas
Jefferson was accused of a sexual affair
sexual misconduct the the original me to
the 19th century mewtwo movement there
was an editorial that that came up in a
number of newspapers and a series of
editorials written by somebody named
Fosse on phot cion this was when Thomas
Jefferson was running against John Adams
to become the second president of the
United States and it accused Thomas
Jefferson of sleeping with his slave and
having children with his slave of a
concubine slave Sally Hemings which it
seems from the historical record is true
who is Foshee on none other than
Alexander Hamilton is it any wonder that
people wanted to kill that guy that they
wanted to challenge him to duels and
shoot him no wonder at all he wrote I
think 25 essays against Jefferson under
this pen name foe see on and it was a it
was a sex affair allegation so I do want
to point out is now that we're
responding against the me2 movement
this has long happened there's a always
been sexual dirt in politics why because
sex is a primal major drive for men
especially and so it's a good way to
attack your political opponents when you
can this has happened for a long time
that said when you've got you know the
entire national news media supporting
these unfounded charges when you've got
no evidence for those charges there was
evidence for the charge against
Jefferson a lot of kids are looking like
Thomas Jefferson on that plantation and
the and Sally Hemings as kids would
always pop out about nine months after
Thomas Jefferson visited and there
weren't any kids that came out nine
months after Jefferson was away from
home so there was some evidence here I'm
not saying that sex scandals are unfair
or they're off the table of course you
know there
gonna be on the table as long as
politics exists but there are degrees
here there's some devil in the details I
know that ideologue want things to be
black and white they want to say Saudi
Arabia bad Turkey good now for some
reason or sex sex scandals are unfair
all this is off the table all this all
that not quite you've got to look into
the details you know all the shallows
are clear All Shall dr. Johnson pointed
this out when when people are talking
about religion or philosophy or politics
or whatever say well that isn't this
isn't clear your point of view isn't
clear it's not ideological I can't write
it down in one doctrine on one pamphlet
of one book or something right shallows
are clear reality is complex reality is
complicated and and and also Jefferson
lost that election I did it was it was a
good attack though he won four years
later so political winds can always
change they're changing now we will see
how they will change for the midterm
elections but we'll have to get to that
next week enjoy another Kingdom another
Kingdom Andrew Clemons narrative podcast
that I perform all the roles in is now
available on audio to everybody non
subscribers and subscribers so go
subscribe download it and if you're a
subscriber you know you get it much
earlier you get it on Mondays you get to
see the whole thing it's a really cool
great artwork do that enjoy the weekend
maybe I'll see you a politican maybe I
won't in any case I'll see you Monday in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018